Sals is an institution and it's the best
pizza in the neighborhood I'm sorry Jake
Sal is only the eighth best I put out a
weekly Brooklyn Pizza ranking email
blast Sals has the fourth best texture
ninth best crust 12th best cheese and
honestly they're only seventh in mouth
feel mouth feel what is that the inside
of your cheeks are very sensitive it's
like the inside of your thighs except
with a tongue oh god look no it's the
best pizza in the neighborhood well
according to Charles's email blast is
actually number eight Captain reads my
blast of course it's the only one that
measures mouth feel what are you kidding
right now whole hour till we
testify hey donut holes don't mind if I
do oh fish fish Donuts boil what is
wrong with you it's takayaki I'm
drowning my sorrows in octopus balls you
know many people think that scrambled
eggs are the easiest food to make but
that is incredibly foolish they are a
highly nuanced and complicated dish okay
now go ahead
and pour your eggs right into the pan
nice and
slow oh okay now what do I do oh boy
okay well you hear that Sizzle that
means the heat is a little too high on
those eggs well the the higher the heat
the faster the eggs cook the sooner
Kevin eats am I incorrect no you make an
excellent point but we don't want to
feed Kevin burned garbage cooking is
about patience are you completely insane
you never salt can a pan the hand the
hand is the middleman okay what you did
is the culinary equivalent of
unprotected
sex you know what you sir are not ready
to scramble
eggs hand over your
spatula
fine I only wish in return I could get
back all the time I just wasted on this
futile project I'm just gonna make Kevin
plain toast for breakfast oh that is low
cluck cluck gobble gobble guess who just
came from the ps321 Thanksgiving Parade
Charles you actually Charles I'm Tommy
gobler and I'm stopped with Thanksgiving
happiness a gobble Goble seriously I
warned you I'm Tommy gobler you silly
Pilgrim okay Tommy gobbler there you go
these are the Davidsons
they want to know what happened to their
missing
grandmother I have some deeply tragic
news for
you Goble Tommy Gobbler's back and he
wants to hear what you turkeys are
thankful for Charles you got to stop I
don't gobble understand people but
Charles gobble gobble gobble gobble your
tail feather is caught in the gobble
door thank you gobble wait
what oh I think your feathers are
ripping Goble
go it's
Halloween I'm surprised you didn't put
on a costume I was going to sir but then
I decided screw that jazz well I'm the
only one who ever dresses up no one ever
gets my costume and they make fun of me
so I'm done these people don't deserve
my dress up
gifts Charles seriously no costume what
the hell Charles where's your Halloween
spirit but you guys always make fun of
me I have never once insulted you in in
my life especially Visa your appearance
yeah man we always love your costumes
remember last year when you came as that
person Andor thing yes I do remember sir
permission to Sprint to my car and get
my emergency costume does it matter if I
say no
no a bam bam
boom what the what why are you dressed
up you look like an idiot but yeah what
are you supposed to be a sassy car
mechanic no come on he's clearly the
rejected Pop-Tarts mascot Harry
Pop-Tarts I am not you know who I am
Squad that's enough you're making boil
for bad on purpose he's Elvis yes Elvis
sto the Canadian figure Gator no hey
guys I just discovered a new drug too
it's called your relationship and I'm
high on it Charles I'm going to need you
to back off man Roger that yeah Amy
Santiago will you marry me Jake ala I
will marry
you I love you so much hey jeros this
little Escape so that ought to
teach did you just mhm and did you say
mhm oh hi I'm starting today detective
Santiago oh detective peral welcome
aboard
I'm hearing Wedding
Bells hi detective boil I'm pregnant
we're
[Music]
pregnant what the hell I thought you
guys would be more excited than that
Charles you didn't even faint I'm so
sorry I'll
try it's not working somebody choked me
on it Rosa sorry we're so happy for you
but we also maybe kind of already knew I
me you didn't do the best job of hiding
it why have you been carrying that box
around so much I just love this box why
you reading that new paper it's 2 days
old I just love this issue hey why are
you wearing that hazmat suit I just love
this look okay fine so you all knew we
were pregnant good for you but I bet you
didn't figure out that we're having
twins no not really it's one baby I just
needed to see Charles
[Music]
faint so how is the restaurant such a
normal time why are you being weird Amy
and I kissed what to keep our cover from
being blown we didn't have a choice
always tell me everything Charles it was
just a kiss okay it was for work it was
nothing yeah who cares about a kiss call
me if you grab each other's
asses I guess I can see it I think it's
amazing oh Jake and Amy and baby makes
three I don't know if I believe in God
but I have prayed for this that is
psychotic okay looks like you and I are
in a good oldfashioned suck off if we
find James and he's unstable Dr take
could talk him down hello Plus on the
ride over he gave me a quickie what a
quick therapy session we talked about so
much did you know that I have a tendency
to be unconsciously sexual it's a real
tough not to bust you're doing it again
oh okay I think I hear it you think you
hear it we all have our thing you're a
musler I'm a boner there's more with
that came from I got a real wet mouth
you got to admit it's a pretty tough
line no it's not time for me to get out
there and spread my way legs get out
there and spread my legs well I either
way no not either way only Wings you are
kneed deep in the thick Rich broth of
Parenthood as requested you will be the
deuce although I still think you should
reconsider that code name nope Deuce
it's like Ace but twice as cool it is
not it's a turd I don't know Jake I'm
afraid I'm going to think about it every
time I look at your crotch then stop
looking at my crotch oh Daddy's going to
dish out some daddy discipline as a
fellow Daddy I approve stop saying Dad
okay Charles our hands are tied so we're
going to have to use our mouths smart
with the tape down with my Sal until you
could slip right out no we'll call
ourselves the night boys kind of sounds
like a male escort service the midnight
men even worse the dark stallions looks
like we're going with the night boys hey
Captain I have a juicy little boil
nugget I'd like to drop on you hey no
nose hair trimming we're here for 8 Days
Jake I don't care it's on the list well
I hope you like nostril Bush nostril
Bush all right this hallway is clear I
think we killed them all it's a regular
paint bath like bubble bath no like
blood bath Charles I know that you're
freaking out and you think you're never
going to be a father but don't worry
there's no way I'm going to let Eleanor
do anything to your precious boy loyo G
all right I'm out she can do what she
wants no no no no no we'll just call
them hostages are you ready to go
streaking what that's what my dad and I
called getting blond streaks in your
hair we used to do to our ponytails on
road trips you just take a little lemon
up top and let the sun do the rest we
call it giving each other roadhead you
just said you called it going streaking
it had a couple names I really don't
think that she did it something's off
about the
case Okay Bo I trust your
gut let's go free and innocent woman
nice dreams are coming true you and me
get my lady off
together I'm sorry Rosa can I talk to
you in private for a second yeah we'll
be right back Bo why don't you show
donger what a fax machine is okay okay
imagine a letter had unprotected sex
with a foone I could take him to the
Russian bath house has he been no I'm
not some weirdo that takes my 8-year-old
to the Russian bath we take our bass at
home together as a family like normal
people the money the private comos I
figured it out you stole my idea to open
a bowling alley and you're going to do
it with
Terry yep that's it Jake finger holes
was our idea I do not think it should be
called finger holes you're not calling
it finger
holes good luck pal accidentally strike
up a little convo about the 99 oh that
seems rather underhanded desperate times
call for Desperate Housewives what
measures I said measures did you go to
my gym uh a now I work out in my garage
throw the tire around grab a couple of
big ropes and do
this m okay according to the tracker B's
at a warehouse on 11th Street ESU is on
site waiting for our go great time to
gear up it's not the best case ever
without some toys oh yeah toys for
boys I don't know if I like that adult
toys still sounds wrong male toys you
know what let's just not call them toys
that's my fault I started it you got it
we'll just call them play Things We will
not let's do this and we'll be done with
plenty of time before n nage wakes up
nikolaj H nikolaj yeah I said it nikolaj
nikolaj not even close nikolaj nikol
almost nikol nage I feel like I'm saying
it you know what it doesn't matter hit
me with the
music